this molecule is an enol we have a
carbonyl and it's in conjugation with an
alkene in the same molecule when we
treat this with a grignard reagent and
treat it with water in a second step
will get addition to the carbonyl of
this compound the grignard acts as a
nucleophile here the electrons push up
onto oxygen we get an alkoxide which we
protonate in the second step with water
to make the alcohol now if we perform
the same reaction but add in a catalytic
amount of copper chloride we get a
completely different product the ethyl
group instead of reacting at the
carbonyl carbon has reacted at the end
of the conjugated system let's look at
the mechanism for this reaction which is
called a conjugate addition it can also
be called a 1/4 addition or a michael
addition in honor of its discoverer the
name 1/4 edition derives from the fact
that if we number the conjugated system
starting with oxygen 1 2 3 4 the
nucleophile adds at the 4 position but
uses the entire conjugated system this
reaction up here can also be called a 1
2 addition because it only has to do
with electrons moving between the atoms
1 & 2 of the conjugated system so when
we have an e known and an appropriate
nucleophile for one for Michael addition
we can draw our arrow pushing this way
the nucleophile bonds here this double
bond shifts over and the electrons go up
onto oxygen now when we work this up
with water or maybe a slightly acidic
solution we can show the carbonyl double
bond reforming and these electrons
attacking the proton if the enolate
protonates on oxygen we get an enol but
that's no problem because this compound
will readily to Tom rise to the ketone
giving us the same product so each of
these routes is a fine way to
all the mechanism so what's going on
here that's changing the way that this
reaction goes such that we get a
different product
well grignard and organolithium reagents
prefer in most cases to add one two
but this here generates a cooperate and
cuprates prefer to add one for we're
gonna get to why near the end of this
video but we see these two contrasting
mechanisms and we have to have a basis
for figuring out when one of these
mechanisms is going to occur over the
other so that we can predict products
now to know whether a given reaction
will produce a one-two addition product
or a one for addition product we have to
consider several factors reaction
conditions can influence 1 2 vs 1 4
addition when this reaction the addition
of the cyanide nucleophile to this he
known here is run at cool temperatures
we get the 1 2 addition product this is
called a cyano hydron however when we
heat this reaction we get the 1 4
product so when we run this reaction at
cool temperatures
cyanide prefers to add 1-2 and when we
run it at warm temperatures cyanide can
add 1 2 as well but that reaction is
reversible and under these equilibrating
conditions we start to funnel to this
product and the product of 1 4 addition
cannot reverse the reaction so let's
look at that mechanism and see why so in
this process some of the cyanide is
going to add to the carbonyl that gives
this intermediate now cyanide is a
pretty stable anion so at warm
temperatures these electrons can push
back down and kick out cn- now some of
the cyanide can add in a 1/4 fashion now
this can become protonated by the HCN in
solution and now there'll be no anion in
the molecule that can kick
this group so under these heated
conditions where the reaction the 1 2
addition becomes reversible we can
funnel all of this to our 1 4 addition
product though we've been looking only
at n owns of ketones there's a variety
of substrates that can have this style
of conjugation let's look at them now
acid chlorides are the most reactive of
the functional derivatives of carboxylic
acids undergoing nucleophilic
displacement here quite readily now a
meds are among the least reactive we
have a lone pair on nitrogen that can
donate in by resonance stabilizing the
carbonyl well that's gonna play a huge
role in whether the substrate prefers to
undergo 1 2 or 1 4 addition the acid
chloride very reactive at a carbonyl
carbon undergoes one two addition much
more readily and these less reactive
functional derivatives that stabilize
the carbonyl by resonance are going to
favor one for addition now even though
we saw up here that grignard reagents
typically promote one two addition when
this amat is treated with an bewdley at
cold temperature the one for product is
the only product observed and is
isolated and very good yield and we get
this product with the butyl group added
at the end of the conjugated system the
final factor that influences the outcome
of the reaction is the nature of the
nucleophile and some nucleophiles are
considered hard and some are considered
soft so let's take a look at some
examples and see what's going on and
what these terms even mean grignard are
considered hard nucleophiles and prefer
to add one to unless the substrate
structure as we've seen prevents that
when the same ino n-- is treated with a
sulfur nucleophile at room temperature
we see one for addition okay let's look
at examples of some of these
nucleophiles and talk about why a hard
nucleophile would prefer one to addition
and a soft nucleophile
would prefer one for now our enum
contains a ketone and ketones have this
nice dipole there's this electronegative
atom and it is on one side of the
molecule double bonded and so what
happens is we get a dipole going in this
direction
this makes the oxygen partially negative
and this carbon consequently is
partially positive we can even draw a
resonance form that puts formal negative
charge on the oxygen and formal positive
charge on the carbon now for a
nucleophile to adhere to add one to the
dominating factor needs to be
electrostatic interactions hard
nucleophiles will add one two because
these tend to be small nucleophiles with
a lot of charge concentrated on a small
atom let's look at some examples the
smaller more electronegative halogens
will prefer to add one two hydroxide and
water contain oxygen a small
electronegative element these are also
hard nucleophiles alkoxides and alcohols
have the same thing going on negative
charge or negative character on oxygen a
small atom other examples include
ammonia grignard reagents which have
lots of ionic character and a lot of
charge concentrated on carbon and
organolithium reagents which also have a
lot of ionic character on the carbon
atom now soft nucleophiles add one for
and the reason for this is because their
addition is not governed by this
electrostatic interaction instead
orbital interactions are going to
dominate a conjugated system like this
will interact with its LUMO and the
nucleophile has the electrons so it has
to interact with its highest occupied
molecular orbital the homo and these
orbital interactions dominate and one
for addition occurs so what are some
examples of soft nucleophiles some very
important ones are iodine the biggest of
the halogens and the least
electronegative sulfur is below oxygen
on the periodic table it's less
electronegative it's larger in size
because it has additional atomic
orbitals and so these are soft
nucleophiles and one for addition will
dominate another important one is
phosphorous based nucleophiles
phosphorus is also very large and will
tend to add 1/4 triphenyl phosphene is
an important soft nucleophile because it
can add 1/4 and then be used to make a
stabilized vidiq reagent the resonance
in enolate spreads out the charge on
them and these are incredibly important
soft nucleophiles that we can use in one
for addition to form carbon-carbon bonds
but of course it can't just be also cut
and dry as hard and soft nucleophiles we
do have some that are borderline let's
look at some examples the azide
nucleophile is borderline we already saw
that the cyanide nucleophile is
borderline and we saw how we could
control that reaction by either cooling
it down to give the 1/2 product or
warming it up to make the reaction
reversible and get the 1/4 product
other examples are primary and secondary
amines and bromine bromine is more
electronegative and smaller than iodine
but larger than fluorine and chlorine so
it's somewhere in the middle so what do
we do when we see examples of these
nucleophiles so when we have these
borderline nucleophiles we'll have to
look at the reaction conditions and see
if it's heated heating the reactions
going to promote one for addition
cooling the reaction will promote one to
addition and the substrate structure is
also going to become very important with
any of these nucleophiles and acid
chloride is going to add one two so if
you're setting up a
problem you can decide what temperature
to show your reaction at and you could
also use if you're promoting one for
addition you could use an ester and amat
or something that's less reactive at the
carbonyl KP here if you learn something
give me a thumbs up on the way out and
for more chemistry subscribe to my
channel